hello everyone and so we are coming
close to
Christmas and uh I've done many
Christmas videos in the past and so I
thought we'd try to take a little bit of
a different Tack and look at one
sentence in the Christmas story a
sentence that since my childhood I was
always confused and wondering about and
even when I was in university I remember
a professor that I had of biblical study
saying you know this is the kind of
statement in Scripture that doesn't
really mean anything that nobody knows
what it really refers to in what it's
talking about and that is the statement
of the Angels the song of the Angels
which is glory to God in the highest or
glory to God in the highest heaven and
on Earth peace to those on whom his
favor rests or peace to those on which
he has Good Will and sometimes it's also
peace on men of Goodwill and so what
exactly does this sentence
mean
this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to the
symbolic
[Applause]
world so the context is pretty clear we
have first of all extremes in the very
story which is is that we have these
Shepherds that are you know tending to
their sheep we always have to remember
that shepherds in the ancient world were
something like the lowest class of
people you know peasants and then and
they're also tending their sheep at
night and so you have two images of two
extremes which is the lowest type of
person but then at the same time the
Darkness at night and in the heavens
appears an angel and ultimately a a
choir of Angels or group of
angels that announced to them that the
Messiah is born in Bethlehem that the
prophecy has been revealed and then they
start to sing this or say this you know
glory to God in the highest and on Earth
peace to those on whom his favor
rests so you have this uh contrast in
the situation which is that the glory of
God shines and so in this case you have
to really understand the glory of God as
light so you have to think of the this
contrast in terms of the situation which
is that it's dark it's night and then
all of a sudden in the heavens appears a
light so there's a contrast between
heaven and night there's a contrast
between the highest and the lowest in
the sense of the figures in the story
which is that the Angels Above and the
Shepherds below
now the shepher it's important to
understand also that the Shepherds in
some ways
are related to being a nomad related to
not necessarily having a fixed place and
moving around with the Sheep you know
tending the Sheep moving following the
Sheep around and and so there's a kind
of uh you could say organic or chaotic
or you know a lack of stability down
here but then above then you have the
Angels now what's important to
understand in terms of the Angels is to
understand the relationship between the
angels and the Stars this is something
that we've talked about on this channel
several times which is that for the
Ancients there was really no difference
between the principalities the angels
that are that were assigned by God to
manifest the patterns of reality and the
stars and the heavens as these points of
light that are up above us and that are
kind of a clock that manifests the the
patterns of reality and so it's
important to see that because if we
don't see that then it'll be difficult
to understand that there's a
relationship between this story of the
Angels appearing to the Shepherds and
the story of the wise men from afar the
wise men from the strange wise men also
seeing the star in the heavens and
following the star to the Messiah or
following The Voice or the song of the
angels to find the Messiah these two are
completely analogous and and help one is
can help you understand the other which
is that what the shepherds are
encountering is something that the
Ancients could call The Music of the
Spheres right the music of the cosmos
the the the deep deep meaning the Deep
patterns of the cosmos this is also
important to understand that when the
Ancients talk about music what they
really mean is the pattern-like quality
of reality and when they would study
music in the ancient world it wasn't
just the way that we think of music as
some of the kind of entertaining sounds
uh that we listen to but rather the
notion that reality has a musicality
that there is a repetition and a pattern
and that this is something that we have
to enter into and what they're
encountering is of course the movement
of the stars in the heavens they're
encountering the pattern of reality uh
there you know both the Shepherds and
the wise
men the wise men are a little different
but they're not that different so
instead of being the lowest in terms of
the shepherd they're The Strangers
they're the ones that don't necessarily
belong in Israel and so there's
something like the the light above the
star above is calling to the like uh you
could say the stars that are far away or
the the glowing Embers the glowing
Sparks that are not from Israel that are
there out in the world the the places
where the glory of God is hidden you
know the wise men who are able to
discern the
signs uh from very far away come in to
find the Israel and so it's similar to
the Shepherds that are far away in the
sense that there are these nomadic
people that are wandering the land they
don't have a fixed place they're the
lowest of society and so they notice the
they hear the angels so understanding
the structure is important in
understanding what exactly that this
sentence means which is what is the
relationship between saying that Glory
goes to the god in the highest heaven
and then on Earth that we find peace on
whom God's favor rests for whom God has
Good Will and so this is really just an
image of this is an image of reality
this is a cosmic image like almost all
of the cosmic images that I've that I've
shown you before which is that it's a
little image of how reality actually
works in its extreme but the way in
which it's happens in the extreme is
also the way it works at smaller levels
in our
existence so let's separate the
statement into the two parts one is of
course giving Glory or or attending
giving up the proper attention the
proper praise to that which is the
highest celebrating the highest in the
best in the proper way which recognizes
what it is okay that's the first part
and then that brings you could say
causes peace on Earth so why does that
cause peace on Earth so the way to
understand it is to is to apply it to
smaller things so that you can
understand how it works and so let's use
a let's use a uh a basketball team again
I like using sport analogies they're the
easiest and they're the easiest to
understand which you could say it's
something
like proper attention to the highest
aspect of the
team brings about peace among the
players and let's say not only peace
among the players but peace among those
on which this highest aspect of the team
finds favor has goodwi towards so the
idea is that if we understand what it is
that we're doing and we aim towards that
highest aspect of what we're doing we
give the proper attention the proper
celebration to what it is that binds us
together in the first place let's say in
terms of a basketball team that is We're
Playing Basketball to win in this way
you know we we have a team name a team
identity we have uh you know a way to
recognize that we are together that
we're not part of the other team that
we're part of this team we have all
these things that kind of bind us and if
we can if we all are able to celebrate
and
participate and raise up the unity of
our team together then what that will do
is it will G bring peace among the
players right the players will stop
thinking of their idiosyncratic desires
they'll stop thinking about the other
things that could that could they could
contend with that they because their all
their focus is on the purpose and the
reason and the highest part then they
will work together towards that purpose
they will have peace among themselves
they won't be fighting because fighting
is basically different people with
different person different purposes that
are in conflict with each other it will
bring them to have peace together but
then it would it's it's the peace is
applied only to that on which the
identity of the team has good favor that
is only the things that fit within that
identity only the things that have you
know that that receive the grace of that
identity you know because if you are
part of the team and you're not in favor
with what the team purpose is like may
maybe let's say you're doing something
else maybe while you're on the team all
you're thinking about is some other
interest your girlfriend or whatever
then there there won't be peace among
for that person because it won't be in
favor of the in the favor of the
identity of the team there's actually
another reading of this verse uh in
different versions of the text which
which is you could also read it in
certain uh versions
as peace on those who have good will
that is peace on the men of Good Will
and that also works it's similar to the
other one which is that for those that
have the right intentions that those
that you know are acting properly within
their attention to the highest goal then
they it will bring peace to them in
their in their Endeavor so you can apply
this now at any single thing that you
that finds unity in uh that finds unity
in multiplicity it can even be in
yourself you know which is that if you
yourself are distracted by different
things and you don't you know Focus your
attention on the highest purpose that
you have at the moment then what will
happen is you won't have peace within
you you'll have conflict within you
you'll have Discord within you and you
and you know it won't it won't work but
if you're able to align your different
aspects of your being into one common
attention which is raised up above all
the others then you will have good will
among those things that are working
towards that attention you'll have peace
I mean you have peace amongst those
things that are working towards that
attention and so now what's going on
here in this story is something like a
cosmic version of that it's like the
extreme version the the the most
encompassing version of that which is if
we praise if we celebrate if we
attribute Glory if we raise up the name
the the the source of all things if we
raise up God in the highest Heaven
that's the God we raise up then there
will be peace on
Earth and so it's like it's showing you
the structure in the sense that this is
what's going on for example in anything
that you do it's showing you the
structure first of all of what Genesis 1
is about which is also about that which
is also
about let's say God is up in the heaven
God attributes unities attributes ways
in which things bind together and those
things if they are well aligned and
they're they're they remain in communion
with God is a good way to say it then
they will be at peace and they will not
be in Discord so it's it's h all the way
back to Genesis 1 and talking about what
is the relationship what is the proper
relationship between Heaven and Earth
and you can imagine that what happens in
Genesis is that man you know takes
things for himself instead of rendering
up to God he tries to take the fruit for
himself he tries to attribute the
qualities of God to himself and
therefore what happens is Discord what
happens is things break down
and they lose the favor of God because
they they're not glorifying him to the
highest they're glorifying themselves to
the highest you know that can help you
understand how this is really this
little verse is really a cosmic image
it's the same thing that happens you
know when Moses goes up the mountain at
SI and gathers the people's attention up
towards a covenant with the highest and
then when they do that what they do what
happens is they receive the law and they
receive the cohesion of the tribes you
know they actually become in some ways a
nation when they all accept a covenant
with which that which is highest in that
case also also with the god of their
ancestors which is that they make an
analogy between that which binds them
together in terms of their lineage and
that which binds them together more
metaphysically that is the god of Heaven
uh and so this was just a little video
to help you kind of see how deep some of
these verses are and how something which
we just sing every Christmas when we
sing you know Gloria in ex chel Deo
um and you know this verse that like I
told you my professor in University said
that they it was just kind of a kind of
like a theological statement with not
much sustenance like it was just
something that people say glory to God
you know and peace on Earth but it
actually is a a powerful Cosmic image
and helps us understand how complexity
Works how attention works and how it all
comes together into the cosmos and into
little microcosms that we participate in
so hope this was useful I want to wish
everybody a Merry Christmas Christ is
born I'm probably saying that a little
bit in advance for you but since I won't
see you on Christmas Day I'm giving
myself the right to say it and I'll see
all of you you know in the in the new
year my next video will probably be
about that about symbolism of the new
year so thanks everybody for your
support for your attention and I'll talk
to you very soon bye-bye